Ce serait donc le nouveau cool.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Qu'est-ce qui est donc
si cool ici?
Pour cet entrepreneur un peu
inventeur, c'est de combattre
l'obsolescence programmée.
JEAN-PHILIPPE ROY, cofondateur
de Mon Atelier de quartier
- Le noyau de mon atelier de
quartier, c'est la réparation.
C'est que les gens puissent
venir et réparer leur objet
brisé et de consommer peut-être
un peu moins.
- C'est peut-être ce genre
d'initiative qui fait
de Villeray l'un des secteurs
les plus populaires de Montréal.
Elsie Lefebvre en sait quelque
chose. Ce classement ressemble
à une médaille pour elle.
ELSIE LEFEBVRE, ancienne
conseillère municipale, Villeray
- On a réussi ensemble à créer
une vision pour le quartier qui
s'articulait autour de trois
choses : vibrant, familial,
vert. Donc, t'sais, c'est
un triangle, pendant 10 ans,
tout ce qu'on a fait comme
investissements, ça visait ça.
- Parce que Villeray n'a pas
toujours été synonyme de qualité
de vie hors pair.
Mais les condos ont poussé
et avec eux, une vague
d'embourgeoisement, qui gagne
aussi le quartier voisin
de Parc-Extension.
Et tout ce monde cohabite
au parc Jarry.
DANIÈLE LEMAY, coalition des
amis du parc Jarry
- Dans ce parc, il y a un mot
important aussi, c'est
l'harmonie, parce que toutes
ces activités, ces gens de
milieux différents, d'horizons
différents, ça s'harmonise très,
très bien actuellement,
et peut-être, c'est ça qui fait
la qualité.
- De l'autre bord de la rue
Jean-Talon, le quartier
de la Petite-Patrie.
- Oh, c'est pas pareil.
(rires)
- D'ailleurs le magazine
"TimeOut" s'égare un peu
en parlant du marché Jean Talon
ou de la Plaza Saint-Hubert,
qui sont tous les deux
dans Rosemont, justement.
Mais plus que des lieux,
la douceur de vivre, ce serait
surtout une question sociale.
- C'est vraiment un endroit
où on vit, où on va
dans les commerces locaux,
où on rencontre son barista puis
on jase avec, puis on peut faire
des liens ensuite avec tout le
monde dans le quartier.
- T'sais, on peut avoir
une famille, mais on n'a pas
envie nécessairement d'avoir
une vie plate, donc l'idée,
c'était que ce soit vibrant.
Et là, donc, on est cool!
C'est un peu ça. On pouvait pas
vraiment dire cool à l'époque
parce que c'était peut-être
pas politiquement correct,
mais l'objectif, c'était ça.
Fait que c'est vraiment wow,
t'sais!
- Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada,